hey 42 here cows can be best friends and
experience stress when they are removed
from each other
welcome to Rick in 1386 a pig in France
was executed by public hanging for the
murder of a child when Beethoven went
deaf he composed his music by hacking
the legs of his piano and sitting on the
floor so that he could feel the
vibrations French was the official
language of England for over 600 years
honey is the only food that never spoils
in New York City approximately 1600
people are bitten by other humans each
year the cold of the room is that you
sleep in the more likely you are to have
a bad dream two-thirds of Africa is in
the northern hemisphere theoretically
the Pope can resign but since he is the
supreme pontiff there is no one
qualified to accept his resignation
beavers teeth never stop growing the
average speed of the wind has fallen by
60% in the last 30 years the average
adult human has one to four kilograms of
bacteria in his or her body you can see
your nose at all times your brain just
chooses to ignore it because it's not
important
Bill Gates hacked into and tweaked his
school's computer programs coding so
that he was placed in a class with
mostly female students the last two
speakers of the Mexican language Zoku
are both in their 70s and refused to
speak to one another almost any domestic
cats can run faster than Usain Bolt
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you